viel streit wenig gemeinsamkeiten auf
der sicherheitskonferenz in münchen
zeigen sich tiefe gräben zwischen den
großmächten gegen bündnisse mit
rechtsextremen zehn tage nach der
ministerpräsidentenwahl in syrien
demonstrieren tausende gegen eine
zusammenarbeit mit der afd
gold für deutsche rodel asse toni eggert
und sascha benecken gewinnen bei den
doppelsitzern erneut den wm titel
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute -nachrichten am samstag mit
viel sport und norbert lehmann ein stück
von mir
welche rolle spielt der westen in der
internationalen politik und wie groß ist
sein einfluss darüber ist auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz am zweiten
tag heute streit entbrannt zwischen
europa und den usa während
us-außenminister pompeo die westliche
dominanz für ungebrochen hält sieht
frankreichs präsident max den westen und
seine werte in der globalen weltordnung
geschwächt deshalb müsse europa viel
stärker zusammenarbeiten mathis feldhoff
es ist ein ungeduldiger appell des
französischen präsidenten mehr europa
mehr zusammenarbeit fordert er
das müsse gelingen ohne die nato und das
bündnis mit den usa aufs spiel zu setzen
und das alles unbedingt gemeinsam mit
deutschland sieht opel franco in dir das
deutsch französische tandem darauf keine
antwort findet auf diese themen eine
perspektive für die mittelschicht ist
das ein historischer fehler hart geht
makro die russische politik an man wisse
um die staatlich gesteuerten
cyberattacken dennoch müsste man mit
russland ins gespräch kommen der
deutschen verteidigungsministerin carmen
heute die rolle zu makro eine antwort zu
geben eine antwort auf die ja schon
lange wartet die aber sehr im vagen
blieb
ich sehe europa und gerade mein land in
der pflicht mehr handlungsfähigkeit und
vor allen dingen mehr willen zum handeln
zu entwickeln denn wir deutsche und
europäer blicken auf eine strategische
lage die immer stärker von der
konkurrenz großer mächte gestimmt wird
und die großen mächte schüren neue
konflikte der us aussenminister knöpft
sich china vor
menschenrechtsverletzungen und spionage
so der vorwurf
die kommunistische partei chinas ist ein
risiko für unsere zentrale idee nicht
für die länder direkt aber für unsere
idee vom westen
alles lüge so der chinesische
außenminister kaum anfang nie sein
redekonzept zur seite gelegt wird auch
er deutlich sie haben ihre
schmierenkampagne und ihre kritik an
china wiederholt das kennen wir schon
auf der großen bühne fetzen sich die
großmächte abseits versucht der deutsche
außenminister mit seinem türkischen
kollegen den konflikt in syrien zu
beruhigen große befürchtung dass es dort
zu einer humanitären katastrophe kommt
wenn die kämpfe die es dort gibt nicht
aufhören und auch seinem russischen
kollegen redet maß ins gewissen denn
auch der konflikt zwischen russland und
der türkei nimmt täglich an schärfe zu
in münchen beobachtet anne gellinek das
zusammentreffen der internationalen
politik für uns markiert den europäern
ja sehr ins gewissen geredet mehr
zusammenzustehen anne hat er sie denn
damit erreicht
die antwort des französischen
präsidenten auf die unübersichtliche
weltlage ist klar makro will mehr europa
sowohl mehr wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit als auch mehr
militärische zusammenarbeit
aber genau diese vertiefung ist in der
eu der 27 höchst umstritten und auch
deutschland hat ziemlich zögerlich auf
die vorschläge von micron reagiert weil
in deutschland die sorge mitschwingt
dass eine verstärkte militärische
zusammenarbeit in europa den
amerikanischen bündnispartner verärgern
könnte
deutschland sieht sich immer noch als
mittler zwischen europa und den usa
us-außenminister pompei ist ja
offensichtlich nach münchen gekommen um
die europäer über das transatlantische
verhältnis zu beruhigen ist ihm das
gelungen
nein ich würde sagen das ist gründlich
schiefgegangen pompeo hat hier eine sehr
aggressive rede gehalten die die
westeuropäer eigentlich noch er in ihrer
sorge bestätigt hat dass das westliche
bündnis vom zerfall bedroht ist er hat
die konsequente america first position
vertreten dass iran das atom abkommen
mit dem iran ist schlecht den chinesen
ist nicht zu trauen und internationale
zusammenarbeit mit diesen ländern
schlichtweg unmöglich applaudiert hat
dieser rede nur die amerikanische
delegation hier im saal
danke für ihre analyse an ebenfalls
thema auf der münchner konferenz der
kampf gegen das corona virus chinas
außenminister spricht von fortschritten
bei der eindämmung in seinem land gibt
es aktuell rund 1500 todesopfer mehr als
66.000 menschen sind infiziert
inzwischen meldet auch europa einen
ersten todesfall in frankreich an bord
eines kreuzfahrtschiffes in japan sind
jetzt auch zwei deutsche infiziert
thomas konsul fasst zusammen
ende einer kreuzfahrt mit endstation
quarantäne an bord der diamond princess
2500 passagiere und das virus auch zwei
deutsche haben sich nun infiziert wie
alle älteren menschen wurden sie am
mittwoch getestet martin luther johann
hat sich nicht angesteckt erkennt die
beiden
im krankenhaus sind gut für sie war ganz
wichtig wir kommen aus dem schiff raus
dass potenziell unsicher ist für uns
denn wer weiß schon ob das gericht die
isolation nur eine stunde pro tag aus
der kabine raus mundschutz das virus
einfach noch zu unbekannt und ein
globales risiko so warnt der chef der
weltgesundheitsorganisation auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz
die welt gibt milliarden dafür aus sich
gegen terrorangriffe zu schützen aber
eher wenig für den angriff eines virus
das viel schädlicher sein könnte und
zerstörerischer in wirtschaftlicher
politischer und sozialer hinsicht europa
meldet inzwischen den ersten todesfall
in diesem pariser krankenhaus starb nun
ein 80-jähriger chinesischer tourist
sein zustand verschlechterte sich
schnell tage lang befand er sich in
kritischen zustand ernst nehmen die lage
auch deutsche behörden am airport
frankfurt und in münchen werden reisende
aus china nun gefragt nach kontakten mit
infizierten und ob sie in betroffenen
gebieten waren vorsorge damit das virus
möglichst nicht weiterreist
auch zehn tage nach der chaotischen
er ist nicht da aber viele hier reden
über thomas kemmerich den
geschäftsführenden thüringer
ministerpräsidentin seitdem seine fdp
fraktion cdu und afd in dem landtag
gewählt haben gilt ja als reizfigur
18.000 demonstranten sind nach
veranstalterangaben nach erfurt gekommen
es ist dringend notwendig und geboten
dass also hier gegen rechts und rechte
politik aufgestanden wird und flagge
gezeigt wird ich weiß nicht was das wird
ich weiß nicht was das meiner meinung
nach das beste wäre wenn jetzt der
thüringer landtag mit den stimmen auch
der cdu und der fdp
bodo ramelow als übergangs
ministerpräsidenten wählen und es dann
zügig neuwahlen gibt
aber das thema neuwahlen polarisiert den
abseits der kundgebung kann sich nicht
jeder mit diesem gedanken anfreunden
dass eine demokratische wahl das ist
demokratie als gewählt wurden finde ich
unpassend von der kanzlerin dann zu
sorgen dass müssen wir das wieder
rückgängig machen dann werden wir halt
so lange bis es passt für die politiker
ob für neuwahlen oder dagegen stabile
verhältnisse sind sicher der wunsch
vieler thüringer
damit die regierungskrise möglichst
schnell beendet werden kann
nach der zerschlagung einer mutmaßlichen
rechtsextremen terrorzelle befinden sich
inzwischen elf verdächtige in
untersuchungshaft
der zwölfte festgenommene wird ebenfalls
noch den ermittlungsrichter am
bundesgerichtshof vorgeführt
die männer alles deutsche sollen
anschläge auf politiker asylbewerber und
muslime geplant haben
sie waren gestern nach razzien in sechs
bundesländern festgenommen worden
in dresden haben mehrere tausend
menschen unter dem motto nazis stören
demonstriert dazu aufgerufen hatte das
bündnis dresden nazifrei
der protest richtete sich gegen einen
sogenannten trauermarsch von mehr als
1000 rechtsextremisten zwei tage nach
dem offiziellen gedenken zum 75
jahrestag der alliierten bombenangriffe
auf dresden einzelne gegendemonstranten
hatten wiederholt versucht die strecke
zu blockieren
die polizei war mit einem großaufgebot
im einsatz
führungswechsel bei der afg in baden
württemberg die fraktionsvorsitzende im
bundestag weiter leitet ab sofort auch
den landesverband im südwesten
54 prozent der stimmen entfielen auf sie
ihr gegenkandidat spanier kam auf gut 41
prozent
zuvor hatte es eine doppelspitze geben
die sich gegenseitig bekämpft hatte
was tun gegen armut im alter
die linke schlägt alarm für zu viele
menschen sei das zu erwartende
rentenniveau bedrohlich niedrig dass
folge aus zahlen des arbeitsministeriums
gefragt hatte die linksfraktion die
bundesregierung hält dagegen die
grundrente werde entscheidend helfen
außerdem soll die renten kommission das
system grundlegend überarbeiten daniel
posten bezieht man alle renten ein auch
erwerbsminderung und
hinterbliebenenrenten lag die
ausgezahlte rente 2018 beim schnitt 829
euro netto wer neu in die rente eintritt
erhält etwa zehn prozent weniger
insgesamt ergab die anfrage der linken
liegen so über 17 millionen gesetzliche
renten unter 1000 euro netto wenn von
25,7 millionen renten 17 millionen unter
1000 euro liegen dann haben wir ein
veritables problem
wir brauchen höhere renten das heißt vor
allen dingen höhere löhne
das ist alles finanzierbar wenn alle
auch abgeordnete beamte selbstständige
einzahlen die bundesregierung verweist
darauf dass betriebliche und private
vorsorge hinzukomme gegen altersarmut
werde zudem die grundrente helfen deren
verabschiedung allerdings hat das
kabinett mehrfach verschoben
trotz vieler offener detailfragen werde
sie aber pünktlich zum ersten ersten
kommen wichtig sei dass vor allem mit
blick auf ostdeutsche rentner
die haben oft besonders lange gearbeitet
aber zu niedrigen löhnen
nun kommen heute deswegen nicht mehr auf
eine auskömmliche rente
hier soll die grundrente einen beitrag
leisten zur generellen überarbeitung des
rentensystems hat sie die regierung
parallel eine renten kommission
eingesetzt sie allerdings droht zu
scheitern beim versuch eine gemeinsame
empfehlung abzugeben die kommission so
mitglied börsch supan hat sich selbst zu
viele fallgruben gegraben die
rentenpolitischen denkverbote eng den
diskussion spielraum so ein dass man
sich nicht mehr bewegen kann etwa beim
renteneintrittsalter
eigentlich wollte die kommission im märz
ihren abschlussbericht vorstellen eine
klausur anfang februar aber endete ohne
gemeinsame linie
blicken wir nach afrika dort versuchen
den menschen eine seit monaten
andauernde heuschreckenplage einzudämmen
und um dieses hier geht es die wüsten
heuschrecke pro tag kann das insekt bis
zu 150 kilometer zurücklegen dabei
frisst ist ganze landstriche karl
betroffen der osten afrikas die riesigen
schwärme pflegen von somalia über
äthiopien bis nach kenia von dort
berichtet tim kröger seit tagen seien
die wüstenheuschrecken in dieser gegend
erzählt uns bäuerin esther mutter die
wie die anderen fahrer versucht sie die
insekten aufzuscheuchen irgendwie aber
allein dieser schwamm besteht aus
millionen exemplaren
wenn das so weitergeht dann zerstören
sie alles und wir haben nichts mehr zu
essen
seit november nimmt die plage zu
gigantische heuschreckenschwärme fallen
über verschiedene regionen ostafrika
zerfressen felder kahl somalia äthiopien
und kenia sind besonders betroffen
erst wenn man das hier mit eigenen augen
gesehen hat dann bekommt man eine ahnung
vom ausmaß dieser heuschreckenplage in
ostafrika und das sieht man in dem man
hier einfach durchläuft verantwortlich
sind die ungewöhnlichen regenmassen der
vergangenen wochen durch die günstige
brutbedingungen für die heuschrecken
entstanden sind die
nahrungsmittelsicherheit von millionen
menschen sei gefährdet die un
organisation für ernährung und
landwirtschaft fao
bald schon im april mai wird in den
meisten ländern neu angepflanzt das
bedeutet wenn wir es nicht schaffen die
heuschrecken population jetzt unter
kontrolle zu bekommen dann wird das
große auswirkungen haben
vor allem mit chemikalien werden wie
heuschrecken am boden und aus der luft
bekämpft am besten bevor sie
geschlechtsreif werden um das
heranwachsen weiterer generationen zu
verhindern
auf die britischen inseln steuert das
zweite wochenende in folge ein massives
sturmtief zu hunderte flüge sind bereits
gestrichen worden
meteorologen rechnen mit heftigen
windböen und großen regenmengen in
nordengland errichten soldaten barrieren
gegen hochwasser experten befürchten
ähnlich wie beim sturmtief am
vergangenen wochenende überschwemmungen
und verkehrsbehinderungen
ausläufer des sturms erreichen morgen
auch den norden deutschlands
und damit sind wir beim wintersport und
norbert und den tollen deutschen
erfolgen im juli bei den frauen da hat
julia taubitz ihren ersten wm titel
verpasst und wurde im russischen sotschi
erneut vize weltmeisterin bei den
männern dagegen gab es das erste gold
bei diesen weltmeisterschaften durch das
thüringer duo toni eggert und sascha
benecken
die faire gratulation zwischen
weltmeistern und bronzemedaillen
gewinnern
auch die deutschen doppelsitzer ist
wieder einmal verlass tobias wendl und
tobias arlt gehen als vorletzter in den
finallauf von fallen dabei hinter die
bis dahin führenden russen dennis f und
antonow zurück dann die spitzenreiter
toni eggert und sascha benecken die
titelverteidiger behalten auch im
zweiten lauf die nerven
und lassen sich den sieg nicht mehr
nehmen die erste gold medaille bei
dieser wm eine erlösung für die deutsche
rodel mannschaft und die zugabe folgt
nur kurze zeit später im olympia
eiskanal von sotschi julia taubitz holt
sich im einsitzer der damen die
silbermedaille mit bahnrekord im zweiten
lauf schiebt sie sich noch von position
vier auf zwei vor
gold und bronze geht an die russin
ekaterina kvitova und victoria
demtschenko und eine weitere winterliche
wm medaille für deutschland gab es im
eisschnelllaufen bei den biathleten aber
geht das warten auf den ersten
wm-podestplatz antholz in südtirol
weiter
während russland mit dem ersten sprint
gold des ehemaligen doping täters
alexander login auf die wm in antholz
feiert hier in der mitte bleibt das
deutsche team weiter in medaillenlos in
südtirol auf platz 7 ohne fehler beim
schießen aber mit fast 40 sekunden
rückstand olympiasieger ankäufer im
schnellsten rennen der geschichte hat
sich patrick beckert mit deutschem
rekord zum dritten mal wm-bronze über
10.000 meter gesichert hinter dem
eingebürgerten kanadier und
olympiasieger ted jan blumen und land
zwar gramm fisch denn zwölf minuten
33,86 sekunden in salt lake city an
weltrekord aufstellt zum ersten mal
nicht auf dem wm-podest die niederlande
stabhochsprung europameister hormon
geplant ist hat seinen erst eine woche
alten eigenen weltrekord um einen
zentimeter verbessert der 20 jährige
schwedische bank beim world indoor
meeting im schottischen glasgow
im ersten versuch über sechs meter 18
die azur fußball-bundesliga da hat
leipzig wieder die tabellenführung
übernommen
durch den souveränen sieg gegen bremen
hier die bisherigen ergebnisse des 22
spieltags rb schlägt werder mit 13 0
hoffenheim unterliegt wolfsburg mit 2 3
augsburg und freiburg trennen sich eins
zu eins paderborn unterliegt er hatte im
ersten spiel ohne trainer jürgen
klinsmann mit 1 2 heimniederlage auch
für union berlin 2 2 gegen leverkusen
bereits gestern besiegte dortmund
frankfurt mit 14 0
morgen dann noch köln gegen bayern und
mainz gegen schalke blick auf die
tabelle leipzig erster dahinter die
bayern die sich morgen aber die tabelle
in führung wieder zurückholen können
dortmund dritter vor leverkusen gladbach
und schalke die zweite tabellenhälfte
die beginnt mit frankfurt und ganz unten
alles unverändert düsseldorf bremen und
paderborn tabellenletzter ja das spiel
das läuft in gladbach was für dich bei
uns im aktuellen sportstudio am 23
bleibt noch das zweigeteilte
sonntagswetter das wird für die einen
stürmisch und regnerisch für die anderen
frühlingshaft mild details gleich von
katja hornisse so viel von uns marietta
slomka und das heute journal um 22 uhr
45 und wir sind morgen abend wieder für
sie da
punkt 7 ihnen noch einen vergnügten
samstagabend schiss